ce sont des douceurs dont le nom fait
sourire les touristes les crocs du chien
de montargis une des spécialités de la
venise du gâtinais
c'est la propriétaire d'une confiserie
de la ville qui a flairé le bon coup il
y a un peu plus de 50 ans s'est amélioré
en 1968 qu'il a créé
puisqu'à l'époque on achetait des
crottes de chocolat et donc elle s'est
dit eh bien je vais m'appuyer sur la
légende du chien et je vais vendre la
crotte de chien de montargis donc qui
est un praliné noisette avec une coque
de nougatine et à chocolat noir cette
confiserie a hérité des brevets et
exploite la recette de cette gourmandise
élaboré en normandie
enveloppé dans son papier doré la crotte
est un bon filon chaque année une tonne
et demie de ses pépites sont vendus
beaucoup de touristes viennent pour la
crotte de chien parce que ils sont
étonnés de voir le nom crocs du chien
donc ils s'étonnent mirandol dans le
magasin et du coup on a énormément
touristes qui viennent pour ce produit
phare un produit phare qui doit son nom
à un célèbre canidés inspiré d'une
légende du moyen-âge un combat singulier
entre un chien et le chevalier macaire
leroy soupçonne ce dernier de
l'assassinât d'un de ses favoris qui
avait un chien ce chien sans doute un
lévrier qui est toujours un chien
aimable mon était toujours très agressif
avec macaire donc leroy cain des doutes
a décidé le jugement de dieu les ordalie
et donc le jugement de dieu c'est un
duel et macaire a eu un moment
d'inattention dans le duel le chien ne
saute à la gorge c'est la scène que l'on
voit ici dans la statue de de bris et
macaire avoue son crime et le roi n'a
fait pendre la légende a eu plusieurs
versions de lieux et d'époque avant de
s'ancrer à montargis depuis le 19e
siècle le canidé est représenté dans
divers lieux de la ville
avec ce bronze qui trône dans le jardin
du musée girodet ou sur ce vitrail de
l'église sainte madeleine
au fil du temps les montargois se sont
appropriés l'histoire de ce chien
courageux et fidèle jusqu'à lui donner
le nom d'une douceur chocolatée